Speaker 1: . OK, so I'm going to be really
honest and transparent with you, I don't know
if Caitlyn Jenner's candidacy for the California
gubernatorial recall election is a serious
campaign or a publicity stunt.
I actually can't tell.
I'm having trouble determining it for myself.
And part of the reason I can't tell is that
every interview that she does is so bizarre
and so disconnected from reality.
And it transmits not only no actual understanding
of the political issues, but not even an interest
in appearing to understand the political issues.
That part of me sort of hopes it's merely
a publicity campaign, because as a political
campaign, it's completely pathetic.
It's in theory, a pretty interesting candidacy.
A Republican transwoman running supporter
of Trump, despite endless hostility from Trump
to the trans community, very much hostility
from Trump ists to the trans community.
And in fact, the last time I covered Caitlyn
Jenner interview, many of you were super interested
in at the last clip about one of her interviews
got over a million views on YouTube that wasn't
even that long ago.
So Jenner is interviewed again this weekend
now that the recall is happening in California,
interviewed by Judge Jeanine Pirro on Fox
News.
And I have to tell you, I am again questioning
Kaitlyn's connection to reality.
She seems not even connected to the most fundamental
and basic facts on the ground in this first
clip.
Somehow, I mean, again, the enemy is George
Soros.
How can it be that it's always George Soros?
Let's start with the first clip
Speaker 2: killing a man on how George Soros
has been funding all these all these lawyers
and loans.
Very liberal lawyer SFD for.
Yes.
And you know this feel very well.
And he keeps running them to getting him giving
as much money as they want because he figures
he's got to change this country from the bottom
up and he wants to destroy this country.
Speaker 1: So there it is.
There is no campaign at which a Republican
can't interject the idea that George Soros
is evil.
Intentions are being promulgated and perpetuated
at every level with his money and lawyers.
And, of course, of course, we can get into
is this just more thinly veiled anti-Semitism?
I don't even think we need to because we have
so many other things to talk about.
You might have also noticed that at the bottom
of the screen, there was a quote of Caitlyn
Jenner saying, we have to get tough on crime.
Whenever I hear tough on crime, I always ask,
which specific crimes are we not tough enough
on?
And also, when get when you say get tough,
what do you mean?
Is it we're not prosecuting enough?
Is it that the punishments aren't strict enough?
Do we need more jail time?
You really have to make them tough.
Tell us tough on crime is meaningless in the
abstract.
Which crimes and what aspect do we need to
be tougher on?
Like if people came to me and then say they
say, David, sir, what crimes are we not tough
enough on?
I would say there's not enough effort being
put into even policing and prosecuting white
collar crime.
And then the sentences are also not nearly
harsh enough.
We are too focused on street crime and including
drug related stuff and not focused enough
on white collar crime.
Most fraud and embezzlement isn't dealt with
harshly enough.
OK, so let's put them in the position of having
to tell us exactly which crimes they're talking
about.
Next clip.
Here Jenner is asked by Jeanine Pirro whether
she'd support Trump in twenty twenty four
and whether Donald Trump should run
Speaker 2: should Donald Trump run in 2024.
That's his decision.
Would you support him if he did?
If I was governor of the state of California?
I would obviously I would support him.
Speaker 1: What now?
What do you mean as governor?
What would would you support him is the question.
Speaker 2: What if you were governor?
Would you still support him?
Yes, I still would support him.
I do not like what's happening in this country
right now.
Speaker 1: So then what's the point of mentioning
if I were governor?
Like, it's all just kind of confused and very
bizarre.
And then let's look at one longer section
about I don't even know what, but it gets
into WOAK and other, you know, buzzwords.
Speaker 2: All right.
Now, you're considered to be one of our nation's
greatest athletes and heroes.
And the moment
Speaker 1: now, is that even true?
I don't even know that that's true.
Is Caitlyn Jenner one of the greatest athletes
in American history?
That it sounds strange to me.
It sounds like maybe Fox News is saying that
because Caitlyn Jenner is a Republican, but
I don't even know.
I mean, I'm not taking anything away from
Jenner's achievements, but that strikes me
as is not really even accurate.
But that's not the point today.
Speaker 2: OK, cross the finish line in 1976
for that decathlon.
Some fan ran across the finish line on the
track and gave you a flag and you wave that
flag proudly.
And that became a very iconic moment, not
just then, but throughout history in terms
of the Olympics.
Right.
How do you compare today to then?
Boy, has it changed.
Remember, that was 1976, our country's bicentennial
year.
We were just three weeks earlier, the biggest
Fourth of July celebration the country's ever
had, celebrating 200 years.
I've seen through the years the accumulation
of our flag of
Speaker 1: the flag has deteriorated.
Now, I'm guessing Caitlyn means a deterioration
of respect for the flag, that that's what
I assume Caitlyn means, which I disagree with.
But it's all just mumbo jumbo mumbo jumbo
confusion, love of country.
Speaker 2: I still love our country.
Oh, OK.
We certainly have issues, but I'm a patriot,
right?
My father my grandfather fought in World War
One.
You know, my my dad stormed the beaches of
Normandy first votes on three hundred and
sixty four guys in his division.
Sixty came back alive, you know, to fight
for our freedoms.
And I've always had that in my heart.
Patriotism.
I love this country.
I was very proud to put that flag up.
But I've seen it go down to where now we just
saw this when the hammer thrower disrespect
our flag.
And then that bothers me.
Let's talk about Gwen Berry.
You know, she came in third place and she
thought it was all about her.
She said they played the national anthem when
they knew that she didn't like it.
She didn't.
She understood that she didn't like.
OK, all right.
All right.
But the United States was her ticket to those
Olympics.
They were the trials that great.
Should she be allowed to go forward when she's
indicated
Speaker 1: that she now this is like a hyper
nationalist perspective.
You are you're there because the U.S. has
sports and you were able to train in your
sport.
And so therefore, no action, even a constitutionally
protected action is allowed because it's inherently
disrespectful to the fact that you should
be only grateful to the United States.
It's a hyper nationalist idea which is accepted
without question on places like Fox News,
Speaker 2: pretty much rejects the flag, rejects
the national anthem.
You don't want that's a tough question, why?
Because I don't I like individual freedoms,
No.
One, I
Speaker 1: think we now this is actually the
right instinct by Caitlyn Jenner.
It's the right instinct
Speaker 2: to individual freedoms.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: I think people like that who are
going to disrespect our flag to make a political
statement and maybe get more hits, you know,
on social media, technically have a right
to do that technically.
Speaker 1: Look at Jeanine's face.
Caitlyn Jenner has the right instincts here,
which is it's I wouldn't even say technically
they have a right to do that.
Displaying 10 flags, if that's what you want
to do, is a constitutionally protected free
speech statement.
And turning away from the flag is as well.
And they're equal under the law.
Speaker 2: But they we also have the right
they have the right to deserve this, the consequences
that will come out of their actions.
Speaker 1: That's right.
And what I wish is that Caitlyn Jenner applied
this same analysis to social media and the
idea that their free speech doesn't mean freedom
from consequences of speech.
And as long as it's not a government sanction,
the Olympics say these are the rules about
how you have to address the flag.
They would be they would be able to do that.
And then people could react to that by saying,
well, I don't like that I'll boycott the Olympics
or whatever.
But Caitlyn Jenner's instinct is actually
it's a moment of clarity and Janine doesn't
like it.
Speaker 2: Are there enough consequences to
someone like that?
Excellent question.
And so many cases, no, sometimes you become
big stars for that, like getting commercials
for Nike and things like that.
That bothers me tremendously.
This woak, that world that we're living in
right now is I don't know, honestly, I don't
know how we move forward.
We have to move forward and be strong.
We have to move forward with love of country.
Speaker 1: So there is the conflict where
Caitlyn actually has the right instincts about
individual freedom but still has to sort of
kowtow to WOAK is bad.
And how do we even deal with WOAK?
So a confused interview, an interesting moment
of clarity.
It's the moment where Jeanine Pirro pushed
back the most.
But big picture, continued confusion sort
of coming out of the pseudo candidacy of Caitlyn
Jenner.
Let me know what
you think.